[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL YOUNG: So I'm Paul Young.
For those of you
who don't know me,
I am the go to market director
for SAP at Google Cloud.
A bit of history, the challenge,
the SAP world's a small family.
And sometimes, these things
are like family reunions.
But there are a few faces in
the crowd that I don't know.
So to give you the history,
I started out my SAP career
with Hewlett Packard.
I was on board with
HP actually launched
for a short release of R3
and got sent on assignment
to [? Waldorf ?] to
help make it run on HP
9000p [INAUDIBLE] machines.
This is a long time ago.
Release 0.9, if you
go that far back.
And bought it, deployed it,
ran it at HP for eight years.
And then SAP said, hey, why
don't you come work for us?
And 20 years later, I was
still working for SAP.
So the plan was never really
to spend 20 years in SAP.
It's just that's how
it all worked out.
So various different
roles, the last seven years
of which I was part
of the management
team for HANA [INAUDIBLE].
And in the last 2
and 1/2, I got asked
to take on a little
side project, which
was working with the cloud
providers on SAP in cloud.
And the more I
did that, the more
it became obvious the
world was going to change
and going to change in
a very significant way.
And you never want to be on
the wrong side of change.
So Google came along a year ago
and asked me to join and take
on the go to market for SAP.
And it's fascinating.
Actually, LinkedIn,
on Monday, auto
generated a message that said,
congratulate Paul on being
one year at Google Cloud.
So all week, I've
just been getting
hammered with emails
of people obviously
hitting the congrats button.
Congrats.
It's like what?
Congrats for
surviving apparently?
I don't know one year is a
particularly significant thing
to do.
I think more significant is
what we've done in that year.
Right?
And so we'll get into the
details and the specifics.
But basically,
nine months ago we
watched the four
terabyte HANA servers.
That was us significantly
entering this market.
And from where we were
then to where we are now,
there's no comparison.
We are charging forwards.
I'll tell you a separate story
really quickly before we enter
the content, which is Sapphire
last year, which was me,
I was walking to Sapphire
with one of our officers
in the CTO team.
And as we were were the
last day of Sapphire,
we're going out
in the escalator.
And he turned to
me and he said, how
do you think we're going
to win in this market?
And I said, what do you mean?
And he said, well, look,
IBM's been in this market
for 40 years.
And they've had some these
customers for 40 years.
HP's been in this market,
the SAP market for 28 years.
We've been in this market
for 16 minutes so far.
Like, how are we actually
going to win in this market?
And my answer to him at
the time was, we're not
going to win in this market.
Well, first of all, I
was here 28 years ago.
I'm well aware of the history.
And I will tell you
right now, we're not
going to win in this market.
What we're going to do is we're
going to change this market.
And we're going to make
everyone else compete with us.
To which, afterwards, long
time afterwards he said,
I looked at you, and I
thought, is he insane?
To the point where I said that.
I'm not insane.
This is a market
that needs to change.
This is a market where
the customers want things
that they've never got.
They didn't get from
their original providers.
the cloud providers.
And we're going to deliver
it to them as part of Google.
So just take that
context in mind
as we go through the rest
of this conversation.
All right?
So first up, imagine many of
you are customers, but imagine
you are a customer.
And for those of you, this is
theater of the mind, people.
For those of you who
are customers, you are.
For the rest of you who
are Google employees,
partners, everything
else, just put yourself
in the mindset of
an SAP customer.
All right?
And it's funny.
When I do this internally,
I always say, this is not
intended to be egocentric.
But a lot of them
look like me, frankly.
Right?
They've been doing
this for 30 years.
The bottom line in all of
this, they're fundamentally
paid not to take risks.
Right?
SAP runs their business.
If SAP is down, their
business doesn't run.
We'll talk about this
a little bit later on.
But I mean, it's funny.
We wrote a slide
a little while ago
on just minimizing downtime.
And we had a life science
customer who came to us,
and the team was debating the
cost of the infrastructure,
the cost of everything else.
And as we went through it, the
CIO said, wait, wait, wait,
wait.
I heard some stuff
in this conversation
about how you could
minimize downtime.
He said well, look, and
if you're in life sciences
right now, either pharmaceutical
or in medical device, what
happens is,
fundamentally, the way
the law is written at
this time that if SAP
isn't up and running,
you can't manufacture.
Right?
If you're in
pharmaceuticals, you're
required to identify for
every pill you manufacture
all the source ingredients,
where they came from,
which batches they came
from, the recipe that
was used to make them, the
production equipment that
was made to use them, right?
If SAP isn't online, you can't
record any of that stuff.
Everything stops.
If you're in the medical device,
if you're making pacemakers,
you're required to identify
all the components,
all the wires, the batteries.
So if something
goes wrong, the FDA
literally you have to
be able to, in fact,
in under an hour come
back and tell them
every patient in the planet
that has that battery embedded
inside their body.
Right?
If SAP isn't online,
the world stops.
Right?
Downtime is a huge thing.
And his example was,
we're debating cost.
We're doing everything else.
No one ever comes to me and
talks about lowering my cost
and increasing my uptime.
Right?
They tell me how I can spend
a lot more to get uptime.
But they don't tell me how I
can do both at the same time.
It's like, just to give you
a perspective, in their case,
they're a $10 billion
a year manufacturer.
His answer is, if
SAP is down, we
have to stop all the
manufacturing plants.
And it costs us a
million dollars an hour
to shut down the
manufacturing plants.
And we've told that story
a number of times since.
And what's becoming
hilarious about this
is the need for other customers
to then one up that story.
And so I told that
story recently,
and a customer came and said,
it's $10 million an hour
for us, or $10 million
an hour when SAP is down.
Right?
And so I get it.
I get the challenge.
I've run these systems myself.
Ultimately, the objective is
to keep it running because it's
what runs the business.
And if the business
isn't running,
you're not making money.
And a lot of your
friends and colleagues
and stock investments
and everything else
are dependent on that.
And so the point where you
say, let's move to the cloud,
you can perceive that as risk.
Candidly, the point
where you say, hey, let's
move to Google Cloud.
All right?
They're the guys that have been
in this business 60 minutes.
Is that really a risk?
All right?
And how do we handle that?
And so it's not.
Right?
We have a very talented
group of people
who know a lot about
SAP who've come here.
We're doing a lot in
engineering that I'll
update you on in order to
make that a very safe bet.
But equally, I've said
this a couple of times
throughout presentations
we've made so far,
I'm also brutally aware that the
number one sales force for SAP
is SAP's own customers, right?
Generally, SAP's customers
buy from SAP's customers.
One of them does something.
They prove it works.
And then they go tell
all their friends.
And they carry through.
And so in that
context, I'll also
just pause at the
start of this here
to say I'm incredibly grateful
for the customers who've
who come to us over the course
of the past nine months.
And we made a very deliberate
strategy of going to market
and saying, look, we can start
small and get small customers
and try to build over the
course of many, many years.
But the reality of
this market, again,
is you start small, you
get a small customer.
You go to the next one,
they say, well, yeah,
but I'm bigger than them.
Will it work for me?
And so we do it the other side.
You're saying, who are the
biggest guys that we can get?
Who are the biggest
customers we can get,
so no one will question that
we're serious about enterprise.
No one will question this works.
No one will question
we can do scale.
And, boy, did the
customers step up.
So I've already been
on stage with McKesson.
Obviously, McKesson
is Fortune 6.
Literally, health care doesn't
work if McKesson isn't working.
Within the past
week, we've announced
that we have their
contract for their SAP
environment among other things.
We've had-- who
else have we had?
We've had Metro on stage.
They're formerly the number
two retailer in Europe.
Home Depot has done
speeches for us recently.
They're number three
retailer in the US.
That's just a small
snapshot of the customers.
You see a lot more names
come out over the period
here for the big
huge customers that
have come to Google
Cloud along the way.
And so that's an incredible
foundation to go from.
And hopefully, we've
set the foundation
in place for everyone to adopt.
That said, that does come back
to, yeah, yeah, yeah, all great
there, Mr. Talking Head.
What are you going to do for me?
So let's talk about you.
So three key
fundamentals that we're
trying to get to here in
SAP on Google Cloud, number
one of which is
simplified deployments.
Two words, a lot of
complexity behind that, right?
But I mean, we'll go
through some of the details.
But what I'll tell you right
now is for almost everybody
else in this business in the
large scale environments,
so anything above
4 terabytes, it's
a 12 week lead time to deliver
a server to you right now
minimum.
For our entire fleet, globally,
all of our SAP equipment
is 30 second provisioning.
30 seconds after
you click console,
you have an SAP server really
ready to go at any scale.
All right?
There's a simplification
part to that,
but there's also it just
unlocks potential in a huge way.
Right?
So instead of saying, hey, I
have a really great idea, boss.
And them saying, yeah,
put a proposal together.
Maybe we'll have some
spare time a year from now
when we've got a server
that's not in use,
and you can play with it.
You can build a
server in 30 seconds.
Then if it makes sense and it
does good for your business,
you can roll forward from there.
No one else is close to that.
Reduced risk becomes a big deal.
We've talk about some of this.
But I won't go into the details.
But again, downtime
matters in a huge way here.
Right?
Availability matters
in a huge way.
Something that we set out
to engineer into our SAP
environments from the start.
Right?
This wasn't let's
just build some boxes
and let the customer
manage this.
There is a clear
recognition from our side
that, historically, high
availability disaster recovery
are a really big
deal for customers,
especially DR is
really hard to do.
You tend to end up in
third party [INAUDIBLE]
you're never entirely sure if
it works or if it doesn't work.
Huge amount of
work from our side
to automate the
deployment of that,
to make it as
secure as possible,
reliable as possible.
So DR happens just by
default, all right?
And you don't have
to spend your time
worrying about the
back end infrastructure
and paying, no thanks to
the consultants in the room,
but paying consultants
to wire all that up.
It just comes out of
the box and works.
All right?
And then intelligence
becomes the last part.
I think this is the
other component where
I think the really
fascinating part of Google
as a company and Google Cloud,
and Google Cloud, I should say,
and the bigger Google in what
we can do for you is this
isn't just, hey, we do boxes.
All right?
The bigger Google has a
huge amount of assets.
When you get into
the work we're doing
with BigQuery and the
relationship to BigQuery.
When you look at the
data sets that we
have, so the cloud for
marketing data set,
where if you're a retailer
or a consumer packaged
goods company or an airline or
anyone else, the data we have,
it's anonymized,
but tells you what's
going on in your
advertising, what's going on
in your target markets.
The ability to join that all
the way through and get a better
algorithm and better decision
making and better results
puts us apart from the
competition, right?
This is not just, how
many boxes do you want?
I think, frankly, the
McKesson guys put it
best, which is, we
just don't view this
as being a move to the cloud.
We view this as a future
architecture for our business.
I'm not sure you say
that about the other guys
in this business.
Right?
But that's where we are.
So with that said, let's get
going on the meat of this.
So this slide deck, or
this particular slide
started, it got it's
first showing actually
at Partner Day Next San
Francisco nine months ago.
And all the players
have a different way
of projecting
their capabilities.
Basically, to give
you a color scheme
of what's going on here,
if it's at the time,
basically, from the middle now,
from the last dark green now
to the left was
what was available.
To the right was what was
promised in the future.
Right?
So there's a 6 terabyte,
7 terabyte, 12 terabyte,
and an 18 terabyte box on there.
At the time, it was
basically, here's
where we are now at four.
Here's where we'll
be in the future.
Right?
And so at Next San
Francisco last year in June,
we stood up and said,
we have a four now.
We will have a six.
Actually, technically,
a seven wasn't
on the list at that point.
We'll have a six, a 12,
and an 18 coming in 2019.
And at the time, we
took a lot of questions.
We took a lot of questions
because, first of all,
no one has ever done, these
are all virtual machines.
And no one has ever
done a virtual machine
bigger than 6 terabytes
before for HANA.
So the first question
was, how are you
going to do a 12 terabyte VM?
How are you going to
do an 18 terabyte VM?
Right?
Is that even possible?
I'll let you know our
secret, by the way,
we had them all running already.
Right?
As a group, our sales
and engineering team,
had to basically
prove this would
work before we were
allowed to preannounce it.
But equally, knowing that and
knowing that only now is it
coming to market, that tells
you the amount of engineering,
testing work we do to make
sure these things are solid.
So yeah, we announced the
12 and 18 then and said,
we're going to do 12
and 18 terabyte servers.
A lot of people
came back and said,
are you really going to do that?
How is that even possible?
Is it even technically possible?
And the short answer is, yes,
because as announced yesterday,
on new slide, there
you go, we have now
made the six and the 12
available in early access
to customers.
So that means they are
already racked in or DCs.
They are available to customers.
You can't go into
console right now
and say, I want a 12
terabyte, because we're still
in the testing phase.
They're in early access.
But if you come to
your rep, and we
pass the message
through to engineering
and say you'd like
to test one, you
can have a six or a 12 terabyte
server to test right now.
They're available.
They will become
available to everyone
hopefully by the half
point of the year,
certified by SAP thereafter,
and available for you
to use at 30 second
provisioning globally.
So I'm not aware of
any of my competition
where you can go
to them and say,
hey, I want a 12
terabyte server,
and they'll say, yeah, sure,
30 seconds from now, done.
Right?
And it's just to give
you an example of where
we're going to, this is an
operation that acts at scale.
Right?
SAP customers act at huge scale.
Questions at the end.
Hold that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PAUL YOUNG: I'm not answering
competitive questions.
Simple answer.
Questions at the end.
So where we get
to, well, I'm going
to throw off track quickly.
Again, this just opens a
world of potential for you.
Right?
That context of, I need a big
server, I have a big server,
off we go, is unique.
And the bit I was
going to say quickly
is, again, where we're different
from all of our competition,
frankly, is the rest
of our competition
tends to build a single box,
certify it, prove it works,
and then say, all
right, now go sell it.
And we'll build some
as we sell them.
We have built,
tested, engineered,
deployed huge capacity already,
so that when it comes online,
customers are just
able to consume.
Right?
We don't intend to come after
this market one box at time.
For the record, I
keep saying box.
Nancy's going to slap
me when I get off
the stage, because
there are no boxes here.
This is an entirely
virtualized environment.
And if you follow
that graph, there's
an 18 terabyte
server the follows
at the end of the year,
all the same rules.
All right?
And so the first
thing that does is
that resets the speed that
you can operate SAP at.
All right?
We'll talk about some
customers in a second.
Actually, I'll jump forward to
one really quickly, Tory Burch.
Tory Burch have done a
couple of speeches for us.
They've been great customers.
So Tory Burch basically
did a greenfield deployment
of S/4 HANA.
Beyond Consulting
is their partner,
who had a prebuilt client
we could work with.
Hitachi oXya is
their MSP partner.
Both have done a tremendous job.
I love what Tory Burch is doing.
But fundamentally, from Tory
Burch signing the contract
to being live, they had a fully
configured system in 16 weeks,
fully rolled out to
their central office
and all their retail stores
in six weeks after that.
And again, put that in context
of most of my competition
will take 12 weeks to
deliver you a server.
And they had a server 30
seconds after they started.
All right?
That sort of stuff
just completely
adjusts the thought process
of how you run projects.
All right?
It's pay by the second,
like I said before.
If you have an idea you want
to trial, if you have something
you want to try out, right
now, the expensive bit
is the hardware.
Right?
There's a giant
big step involved
in getting the hardware
together to trial something.
And it ain't expensive.
Provision it, run it by the
second, turn it off again.
And this is a bit for the SAP
practitioners in the audience.
So this isn't just, hey,
we're one more place where
you can run SAP, right?
This is not SAP hosting, right?
This is a completely
new operating paradigm
where you can restructure
how you run projects.
And apply that properly, and
it's incredibly valuable.
And with that, I'll just
highlight, as much as I said,
I'll clarify.
I won't do specific comparisons
with specific competitors
by name.
That's a rule.
What I will do, however, is
I'll give you a comparison
of other providers to us.
all right?
So left hand side
is other providers.
If you want a 12 terabyte
server from any other providers
right now, you have
to place an order.
It typically takes 12 weeks.
And you have to pay up
front for the server,
because it's hosting
by any other name.
It's not cloud.
It's not elastic.
You are paying them
for the server,
for them to buy it and
deploy it and then rent it
to you on a fixed three
or five year contract.
It's hardware
running in the cloud.
It's hosting.
It's not cloud as
I understand it.
So here is my understanding
having done this job.
Most of you don't actually
need that capacity right now.
Right?
So for the history of time,
the way it works at SAP
is when you want to
deploy a new environment,
you go to SAP Quick Sizer,
and you put in all the details
of what you think will be the
busiest hour in the next three
years with the most
number of users
and the most number
of transactions.
And Quick Sizer comes back
and says, to handle that hour,
you will require
this much hardware.
Then you go buy that much
hardware and you plug it in.
Technically, you don't
buy that much hardware.
What you then do is you
go, what if I'm wrong?
So you add 10%.
And the next up line goes,
well, what if he was wrong?
And you add 10%.
And you buy way more hardware
that you need in the hope
that, three years from
now, you're right.
And I have a question I've used
in a lot of these speeches.
So if you've heard it
before, please don't cheat.
But I was actually
at the CX forum
for all SAP's conference
for us retailers.
And from the stage I
said, well, two things,
number one of which, does
anyone in the audience
know why Quick Sizer works
on a three year timeline?
Does anyone in the audience
know why SAP picked three years?
I like the puzzled
looks I'm getting here.
It's a question no
one ever thought of.
I'll tell you why, because,
once again, I was there.
Quick Sizer runs
over three years
because hardware depreciates
over three years.
And the plan was build
Quick Sizer for three years,
so when we get to year
three, and you discover
it's too small, it'll
already have depreciated
and so no one is going to
complain about the cost.
There's no business
reason for three years.
There's no operation
It was driven by
hardware depreciation.
But every SAP customer
has done it that way
from the beginning of time.
Why?
Right?
And the second question I
asked in the retail store
was, this was late 2018,
so my question was,
so if we've got to go
three years in the future,
let's go three years back.
Anyone in the audience
know what the best selling
toy was at Christmas of 2015?
No?
I'll help you.
It was an Elsa doll,
because "Frozen" was out.
And the fact that none of us
knows that means we barely
know anything about history.
So anyone who wants to
tell me what the size
they need in 2022 for their
business, please step up.
Even better, anyone
in the audience that
knows the best
selling toy in 2022,
please come talk to me because
we're in the wrong business.
Right?
We should know by now, the
future is not predictable.
Right?
We have no idea what's going
to happen with our companies.
We have no idea
how fast they grow.
who we merge with.
We have no idea who we buy.
But we go and we
do a Quick Sizer
and we take our best
guess at where we're
going to be for three years.
And then we try and fit
the business back to that.
My question always is, so
you go, you make your plan.
You're done.
You buy all your hardware.
It sets up.
You're setting your contract
with a cloud provider.
And the CEO walks in
the office and goes,
we're going to do a merger.
What do you do then?
Right?
And the answer is
write all that cost off
in project cost for the merger.
It's not efficient.
So let's roll back.
Let's say I don't
know how big you're
going to be in three years.
Let's say you don't know how big
you're going to be three years.
Let's say we don't care
because we don't care.
My answer when customers
ask me about this is, look,
I only really care about
two questions on this slide.
Number one of which is, tell
me how big you are right now,
and tell me you
don't honestly think
that in the next three
years you'll go off
the top end of that chart.
As long as those two things
are true, we have a deal.
All right?
So let's imagine that right
now, you're rolling out S/4.
You're growing.
You're doing consolidations.
You're doing everything else.
And you go to the other
guys, and the other guys
say, hey, you know, you need 12
terabytes three years from now.
So I need you to sign
a three year contract,
take a 12 terabyte
system, pay it up front,
and you'll be good.
Right?
That's the left side.
Let's say you come
to Google Cloud,
and you say, hey, I
need 4 terabytes now.
I need eight in next year.
And I need 12 in the third year.
I could do that.
All I need you to do is say,
this is what I need now.
And then as you grow, you just
grow the consumption on the VM.
You just resize the VM upwards
as you go, and it happens.
And you just pay me
for what you're using,
not what you'll need in
three years from now, right?
I've taken the risk
out of this equation.
All you need to do is pay me
for what you need right now.
That dark blue box, by
the way, is the difference
in price for a 12 terabyte.
If you take a 12 terabyte
commit from the other guys,
or you come to me and you
step up a four and an eight
and a 12 as you need it, the
savings, that dark blue box,
is $550,000 per server at least.
You need four of
them to start with.
This is not a small
amount of money.
And it applies across
the entire fleet.
There is a retailer.
I won't name them, but
there is a large retailer
we're working with who is
doing exactly this right now.
Instead of doing a
three year sizing,
instead of doing a year sizing,
what they've basically done
is size June, July, and they've
committed to the June, July
capacity they need.
And for most of the year,
they run June, July capacity.
And then October,
they come through
and say, what does Christmas
look like this year?
And they come and
effectively spot
buy capacity from
us for October,
sorry, for November, December,
and the first half of January.
And then they give
it back to us,
and they resize back to
what they think next year
looks like in capacity.
Do the math in your heads for
how much money that saves you.
Right?
And so I'll go back to
that earlier statement.
I left Sapphire last
year with a statement,
which is, we're not going to try
and compete in this business.
We're going to
change this business.
And we're going to make
everyone else compete with us.
Right?
And it's been a long, hard run.
And I'm very appreciative
for everything that was done.
But as that six and
that 12 comes online,
as the 18 comes online
in the end of the year,
the world's going to change.
Right?
Candidly, my biggest problem
I have right now is we
still get our fees in
from consultants who've
run Quick Sizer and
said, the customer
want this three years from now.
I'm like, no.
They don't want this
three years from now.
They want a minimal
cost operation that
flexes with them as they go.
They just didn't
know it was possible.
Right?
Politely, the help
I need from you guys
as customers and
partners is I need
you to recognize the point
where you come in for a bid
to tell whoever's
doing the bid for you
that you want this flexibility.
Right?
We've built the foundation.
Ultimately, by the way, you
guys will change the world.
Right?
We're just giving you
the ability to do it.
This is the part where
now Nancy thinks,
Paul sounds like he's insane.
But anyway.
Reduced risk, let's
talk about reduced risk.
So when you get to operation
with Google Cloud, so great.
We're cheaper and
everything else.
Is it enough?
Well, again, I've
lived this life.
I've lived this
life myself where
I'm old enough that I've
lived this life when I used
to carry a pager, a real pager.
And I'd get paged and
say, the systems are down.
And I actually, to tell the
truth, I started work for HP.
I used to carry a dial in
terminal in the trunk of my car
and have to find an acoustic
coupler and plug it in.
That dates me for age.
But I've lived this life.
Right?
None of us want to deal with,
hey, the system's not working.
Right?
None of us want to deal with
the argument where the CFO says,
I know we have security
patches, but we've
got to get the
financial results out.
Why do you have to make
that compromise at all?
Right?
And so one of the
key things that we
work at in engineering is, OK,
if we're going to go entirely
VM based, so if we're
going to go for a 100% VM
infrastructure, what
can we do better?
Right?
There has to be
other capabilities.
And so I'll give
you one right now.
So we have a tool
called live migration.
It applies to all of
our fleet, by the way.
But it really
works well for HANA
and for the SAP applications.
So what live
migration does is you
are running your SAP
environment, application
servers, database
servers, everything
else on a set of VMs.
Right?
And what happens right
now is, so let's take
Meltdown and Spectre.
One of the big security
patches comes along.
Every other provider on
the planet, what happens
is you get an email on Patch
Tuesday that basically says,
hey, there is a major
security vulnerability.
All your machines have to
be patched within 72 hours.
So this is Tuesday.
I'm not aware of a
single SAP customer
in the world who schedules
downtime Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, or Friday.
Right?
But you don't have an option
because you have 72 hours,
and that's what
you've got to do.
So you now have to take an
unscheduled outage in order
to do the patch.
Now what a lot of
other guys will say,
well, we have
automatic patching.
Yeah, you do.
But you got to shut
the system down.
And then on reboot, it
automatically patches.
And you're going
to take an outage.
It doesn't count as an
outage for SLA purposes,
but SAP ain't running.
So as far as you're
concerned, you're out.
Right?
Why does that have to happen?
What we do with live migration
is something very different.
At the point where we have
a security patch that's
ready to go, and because
we're entirely VM based,
in the rack, the same rack
close to where your SAP
environment is
running, a second VM
will start up,
exactly the same size
and shape as the current
VM that you're running.
It will get prepatched
for security.
And then a process
will run that will
sync the contents of
memory, CPU, and disk
from the server you're
currently running
on to the new server that's
been patched while it continues
to run.
SAP continues to run completely.
Systems aren't aware.
The users are
completely unaware.
But it is being
replicated as it goes.
And at completion,
when we achieve sync,
the network will take a
millisecond pause, basically,
to allow the original server
you were running on to drop out,
the new server to take over.
The data will start flowing
into it and with zero downtime
and an imperceptible
network pause,
you will be fully
patched with no downtime
across your entire SAP fleet,
across your entire fleet,
everything you run.
So do the math.
Right?
Every time you need to
do a security patch,
you don't need to
do a security patch.
We handle it all for you.
And the really cool
part in all this
is, as much as I
say, everybody else
emails you on
Tuesday to tell you
you need to down your systems.
And then you have to
go into chaos mode
to manage that and shut it down.
We don't email you on Tuesday.
If the flag is set
on the hypervisor,
we prepatch this before the
security alert goes out.
It happens completely
automatically.
You can turn it, off by
the way, if you want to.
Don't turn it all the way off.
But you can actually
turn it off and say,
I would like to choose
the point in time
when it happens over the
course of the next 72 hours.
Nobody does, but you can.
If you don't believe this,
by the way, it's funny,
we had a customer
who said, well, this
all sounds too good to be true.
And so we actually racked them
a system with primary and HA
and Brussels one, Brussels
two, DR in London,
all running with an escort
system running on top of it.
And we said, have at it.
Do what you want.
And the log file shows is
seven times in the first hour,
they pushed test live migration
while putting transactions in.
And an hour later, they
called us and said, hey,
this thing really works.
Yeah, we knew.
But you had to prove
it to yourself.
And that's OK.
All right?
You can test it yourself.
You can provision a server,
deploy it, hit the button.
It'll work.
And again, just do that math.
And that's politely I
will say one of the things
we've been working on.
Today is not the day to go
through all our box of tricks.
But there's a lot more tricks
to come, all right, all of which
are focused on the
life of an SAP customer
and in getting rid of
all the things they
care about, right, sizing,
downtime, all of that stuff.
We've built an
environment where I
can deal with those
problems in a way
that no one's done it before.
We talked about this already.
But again, $10 billion
manufacturer, it's
a million dollars per
hour in lost revenue.
Three hours,
basically, because it's
not just shutting down a single
server and rebooting it, right?
You have to shut down the
entire cluster, all the support
in GRC, GTX, everything else.
You have to patch them all.
You have to reboot them all
in the correct sequence.
It's a huge amount of times.
It's three hours every
time they shut down.
It's $3 million every time
there's an outage to $0.
You don't have to
do too many of those
before, frankly, I've
built you in revenue way
more than my entire
contract costs.
Right?
The game's about to change.
With that, I'll also
give a quick high five
to Intel Optane.
One of the bigger challenges
is that it varies depending
on customer,
depending on chipset,
but in general, per
terabyte of HANA on reboot,
it takes about an
hour per terabyte
to get back to full capacity
and operational run.
So if you're running
a 1 terabyte HANA,
that's a problem.
Right?
If you're running
a 4 terabyte HANA,
you're looking at about three
hours potentially 45 minutes
to recovery.
You're looking at three hours
of either non-performance
or decreased performance.
If you're running a big server,
12 or an 18 terabyte server,
that number becomes a
significant encumbrance to you.
Right?
The reboot time becomes
the vastly biggest part
of this problem.
And so one of things we've
been doing with Intel
is deploying Optane.
That, by the way, is that
7 terabyte box that's
sitting on that chart
right now, which is it's
the first release of
a cascade leak server.
It's the first release
of Optane server.
And, by the way, it
was also the first VM
bigger than 6 terabytes
available in market.
And it's Optane based.
So what happens with
the Optane chips
is they are non-volatile RAM.
So without getting into
some of the specifics
that I'm not allowed
to disclose right now,
a significant
percentage of your data
is actually in non-volatile RAM.
And so when HANA shuts
down and restarts,
our hypervisor understands
where you were.
It reallocates you the
same non-volatile RAM
you had before that already
has your data in it.
It's just going to populate
the little bit of data that
is the stuff that's
changing most frequently,
and you're fully
operational again.
And so instead of taking
three hours of outage,
you're taking 15
minutes of outage.
All right?
So that's future as we walk
through the engineering.
But we're probably with
Intel about the work
we've been doing.
But you know, again,
huge impact, right?
We're working to minimize
the number of events
and the amount of time that
you would have to actually
take an SAP server down.
But there will always exist
times when you have to.
And so to the extent we
can reboot, reboot matters.
Right?
Reboot costs you money.
And I can deal with
that as it goes.
Huge deal.
And like I said, much more
to come as we go forwards.
And just I'll also
pause a second
to say that 7
terabyte server, just
to show how far Google
has come, and because I
get the question a lot
from SAP people about,
why would you choose
to go to Google?
And the quick answer
is the engineering here
is just insane.
All right?
The engineering is insane.
To give you a point in
time, again, last June,
we launched a 4
terabyte server, a week
after Microsoft
launched theirs, a year
after Amazon launched theirs.
Six months later, we launched
the first Optane server,
the first cascade leak
server, the first VM
that's ever been built
over 6 terabytes for HANA.
There's just a
data point for you
on the commitment we're making
to the SAP space and the speed
we are changing this space at.
All right?
We've just launched the
largest VM available in market
ever for HANA.
We're only just getting started.
We're only nine months in.
Wait until you see what follows.
The other part I'll
quickly hand out to you
is we build on top of
everything that is Google Cloud.
Right?
It's an interesting one,
because also, a longtime part
of the conversation you get
with SAP and SAP customers
is, OK, well, how
close are you to me?
Right?
So how close are your
data centers to me?
And frankly, a lot
of our providers
will say, well, I'm
really close to you.
I have lots of data centers.
I'm really close to you.
Again, I ran a
global SAP system.
I think a lot of you in
the audience do as well.
I don't think it's necessarily
how close am I to you,
because you is a
lot of users who
are spread all over the world.
And it's how fast can you
get data to them, right?
What you're looking at is
the Google Cloud network.
If you can imagine
from the loops there,
there actually is a world
map hidden behind that.
That's currently not
projected through.
There is a classic world map.
Asia's on the east.
Africa is on the west there.
America's in the middle.
You can tell from the names.
Huge amounts of capacity
in this network.
So the Dunant cable that's going
in between Virginia and France,
we provided some
details on this.
That cable is ours
wholly owned by us.
All of this is wholly
owned and operated by us.
That Dunant cable on its own
is us, owned by Google Cloud,
and is 250 terabytes per second.
You can transfer
the entire contents
of the Library of Congress from
Virginia to France three times
a second.
And that's just one
of those cables.
All right?
So the same network that we run
YouTube on, the same network
we run Gmail on, all the
capabilities that that
has now also running all your
data backwards and forwards.
It's one of the reasons
why, frankly, we
do so well in retail is the
retail guys are like, well,
I've got to get out
all the retail stores.
And, how do I handle it?
And it's a simple
question, right,
which is, do your employees use
Gmail and YouTube in the store?
Yes, they do.
What's performance like?
Pretty good.
Same network.
All right?
And so, politely,
I'll say, there
is a difference here, right?
We have a significant
data center footprint
globally right now.
But I will politely argue
that the answer is not,
we have a little data
center close to you
to run your SAP environment.
The answer is, do you have
the performance I need,
and do you have the network to
deliver it out to everywhere
I need to deliver to?
And, oh, yeah, we have that.
There's a whole separate
conversation about security.
We do security incredibly well.
In this case, we own data from
pretty much your doorstep,
almost your doorstep all the
way through the network, fully
secure, no handoffs,
no third parties.
No, hey, you bring
your data to us.
It's all managed.
There's a whole
separate conversation
about what we do in that space.
Metro [INAUDIBLE] I'm
going to come back to this.
So last one, really quickly.
Actually, no, there's a
slide is missing here,
but I'll talk to
it really quickly.
Just to give you a
secondary concept
about what goes on with
VMs and how we manage risk
and how we handle structure.
So what I said to
you earlier is, well,
let's say you need a 12, right?
You need four now.
And then you need 12, and you
go into an interesting use case.
I'll give you a
different scenario.
Let's say you're Metro.
So Metro has, they
will probably commit
to over 100 SAP systems that are
consolidated into a single S/4
system.
And every time we do this,
someone in the audience says,
wait.
They have 100, like dev
and QE, and production.
No.
They have 100 standalone ERP
production systems, over 100.
They operate in 25 countries.
They have four live
ERPs per country
because every
division was allowed
to stand up their own
system in their own country.
And the corporate
objective is to get back
to one S/4 system, right?
So over the course
of a number of years,
we're going to do that.
What makes this interesting and
fascinating in this space again
with what we're doing with
virtual machines is what
everyone else would do is say,
well, three years from now,
you're going to
need a 12 terabyte.
Right?
But by the way,
we're going to need
100 1 terabytes and half
terabytes and everything else
along the way.
So here's the total package
you have to buy up front
now and rack and handle.
When you come to
us, the other part
I didn't tell you about
earlier, but when you come to us
and you say, I need
this amount of capacity.
I actually don't need to know
what shape you need it in.
If you need 12
terabytes total, I
don't need to know that you
need one six and three twos.
Don't care.
You're buying 12 terabytes
of capacity from me.
You can shape them
and reshape them
as you want through the
course of the project.
So if you're Metro,
and you're starting,
you can contract 12
terabytes from us.
Day one, you can rack them as
24 half terabyte HANA systems.
Day two, you can say,
I don't like that.
I'd like six 1 terabytes
and 12 half terabytes.
Great.
Just reshape them.
Doesn't hurt me.
Doesn't cost anything.
And then you come along
and say, well, we're
starting to consolidate.
What I want is a
four and eight ones.
Great, four and eight ones.
Now, I want a six
and three twos.
Great, a six and three twos.
Then you say, what
I want is a 12.
Have a 12.
Completely within your control.
30 seconds to reshape.
You buy capacity, and
you can restructure it
any way you want.
You can move it between
QE and production,
and dev and production.
You can spin off test systems.
If you need additional
capacity, you can just
buy it from me by the second.
Again, risk management, cost
management, operational,
never been done before.
I'm not aware anyone
is going to match us.
Right?
But the potential that
unlocks in the SAP customer
base and the ability that
gives you is quite incredible.
All right?
Because we go back to
that conversation of,
why do I need to do a
three year Quick Sizer?
I'm not buying a box, right?
Well, all I need to
know is what capacity
do you need for this year and
then what additional capacity
you need for next year.
If you want some
bursting capacity,
you can have bursting capacity.
This isn't one more
hosting provider, right?
This is a complete rewrite of
the rules of how you run SAP.
And we're right there
where we've just
delivered the hardware
class that does it.
I've got to spend a lot of
time on stages like this
having that conversation.
Last part, however, all
these conversations,
I've done this I
said for year 30 now.
Luckily, LinkedIn doesn't
send a message saying,
Paul Young is one
year at Google.
And he's very old.
So in any of these
sales cycles, right,
in any of these
processes that you
go through, it's one thing to
say, hey, Google's really cool.
And it's safer.
And it's more risk averse.
And it's probably a bit cheaper.
There's still a
huge business risk
that goes with change,
right, that has
nothing to do with technology.
User retraining, upgrades,
testing, there's [INAUDIBLE]..
So there's got to be something
else on the other side.
What I think is
fascinating here is,
typically, we've relied on SAP,
we've relied on the partners,
we've relied on that stuff to
provide the something else.
What I couldn't find at
any of the other providers
was something else.
They we're quite happy to have
you Quick Size, sell you boxes,
and be done.
But I want to be more
than that to you.
I want to be a much
better partner.
So inside that, we've been
working on the something else,
right?
So in the case of
BigQuery, BigQuery is now
pre-integrated with SAP, right?
So you can start
Google BigQuery.
You can you put data
into Google BigQuery.
You can join it to
SAP in real time
and do real-time analytics where
you have Google data and SAP
data.
So on its own, you're
going to say, yeah, cool.
I mean, BigQuery is a
very, very cool tool.
It's just crushing the
industry right now.
However, it's crushing it, I
should say, in the industry.
However, it's an analytic tool.
So what?
Once again, I will go back to,
yeah, but we have a set of data
sets that we can put
into BigQuery for you.
Right?
We will give you an anonymized
data set of your advertising
as it is running in
Google that you can then
link back to the
geographic locations
where you have inventory.
And you can do far better
planning than you used to.
Right?
And that puts me in a place
where I'm not just a technology
provider for boxes for SAP, I'm
an innovation partner for you
because I can deal
with analytics.
I can deal with algorithm.
I can apply machine
learning to it.
There's a lot of stuff
I can now do, right?
So if the inventory systems
says there's four in the store,
and it hasn't sold any
in the past eight hours,
you can be pretty
certain all four of them
have been stolen, right?
And you won't find that
until you go to the shelf.
But you can actually
see it in the data.
You can run the calculation.
And the challenge
of Home Depot Canada
is the supply lines are so long
for some of the their stores
that by the time you
detect that, it could
be a day from now
when you detect that,
because there's huge data sets.
It's all point of sale
data and everything else.
So by the time you detect that,
it could be a day from now.
And then it'll take
another day to get it
on the next truck
that's going there.
So you could be three days
out of stock on the item.
And the answer is
so a bunch of that
as well as moving [INAUDIBLE]
and S/4 into Google Cloud
and running it live there,
they also stood up BigQuery.
And inside BigQuery, they're
running that velocity
algorithm.
And instead of
running it once a day,
which is what they
were doing before,
it runs every 15 minutes.
So every 15 minutes, they
get the likely suspects
for what is not in store.
And that way, instead
of it being 72 hours,
you start to shrink
it down to 24 hours
before it's replenished.
Right?
The world is full of
those opportunities.
And again, we've tried to
build the best environment
we can build to run SAP.
But we've also integrated
it through to a whole bunch
of other technology
where this isn't just,
hey, what you had over there
is going to run over here.
This is something much better.
I said a year ago
when I started this,
every conversation
started with, we just
want to do a lift and shift.
We just want to lift and shift.
Frankly, I never understood
the concept of lift and shift.
If it runs OK over
there, where is the value
in running it over
here, especially
in SAP, where we have
to do all the testing
and all the rerouting of
interfaces and everything else,
right?
There's got to be
something more.
Right?
And so again, the something
more is better uptime.
The something more is way
more flexible pricing.
The something more is
vastly improved analytics,
vastly improved
business outcomes.
And that's why we
believe we're a better
partner for the long term.
Last thing, however, is this.
But you guys know
my favorite thing?
What you're looking at is
as a MiR lifter shifter.
So basically, it's a
robot you dispatches off,
where you say, hey, go over
there, pick up that pallet,
bring it back to me, drop it.
So if I'm running pick
pack operations in a DC,
or if I'm doing
store shelf packing,
basically, you dispatch it off.
It grabs the stuff to you.
You stick it in boxes.
It does the walking for you.
And you carry it through.
Very cool.
One of the things we
look at in Google world
is, OK, how can we again
extend and help our customers.
So what we had, we actually
showed this at TechEd Las Vegas
last year with SAP.
We had one of these
walking around the floor.
We took one to TechEd
Barcelona as well.
Pre-integrated to SAP.
So robots are hard, right?
By the time you
deploy them, you've
got to wire up the networks.
You've got to do the security.
You've got to do
all the programming.
[INAUDIBLE] The MiR,
we don't make the MiR,
but we've embedded a Google
technology package in the MiR.
You basically turn it on,
connect it to your Wi-Fi,
and inside Google Cloud, you
register the serial number
and say, hey, I own this MiR.
And it connects up
automatically to SAP.
And it's that simple.
You really say, hey,
I need you to go over
here, grab this shelving
unit, and bring it back to me.
And SAP communicates
to Google Cloud.
Google Cloud communicates
to the robot.
Robot goes grabs
it and come back.
Huge deal to start with, right?
That very cool?
What I'll tell you, however,
is something even cooler
than that.
So I've just missed
it on timing here.
But when the robot, I mean,
clearly, 17 times a minute
this doofus parks a forklift
in front of this robot.
When he parks the robot,
so it detects the forklift
and walks around it.
When it walks around
it, look at the front.
There's two holes in
the front of this robot.
The two holes are cameras.
So obviously, it has to be
able to see the forklift.
It has to be able to do
a bunch of other stuff.
But let me tell you
what else it does.
As it walks around, it's able
to see the shelves, right?
So when it loops
back around here,
it's able to see the shelves.
It's able to see the boxes.
And it's going to break them
down into a set of boxes.
And on those boxes, it's
going to read the text.
It's going to read
the serial numbers.
It's going to read the barcodes.
It's going to read labels.
And it's going to call back
to SAP, and it's going to say,
I am right now at
this point in store,
in warehouse, in
wherever I am, and I
believe I have seven of these
things in this location.
Is that what you believe
you have in inventory?
Continuous cyclical inventory.
Drop it in.
Turn it on.
Connect it to the Wi-Fi.
And register it.
We are not just a provider
of boxes to host SAP.
Right?
We are on a far different track.
We are going to
change this business.
I'll give you one last thought
on the robots, by the way.
Let's say you're in an industry
like oil and gas, or airplane,
whatever, where you have things
that don't come in boxes.
What happens then?
What we demonstrated at
both Barcelona and in Vegas
is we're also integrating
with a 3D scanner,
not a 3D scanner like on
your desktop, great big giant
thing on an arm.
And so let's say
you have oil pumps.
When the oil pump comes in
the factory, you sit it down.
You roll the 3D
scanner around it.
It will image the 3D scanner.
The geometry patterns are
uploaded into the robots.
As the robots go around and
they see an item on a shelf,
and they basically say, yeah,
you know what, I see that.
It can't find a text on it.
It can't find a serial number.
It can't fit a barcode.
So I went into
geometry analysis.
It's about this long.
It's about this [INAUDIBLE]
it has this many bolts
on the end of it.
What do you think it is?
It's a pump 1152 rev three.
Cool.
There's a pump 1152 rev three
sitting at this location
in the warehouse.
I'm not aware of anyone
else that's talking
about doing all of this stuff.
And again, this is the
total package, right?
Where we are reinventing
how it runs, making this
massively easier.
30 second provision globally.
Making it much
simpler to consume,
much cheaper to consume,
way higher uptime.
And then you add
in the analytics,
you add in the robotics,
there's a ton of other stuff
we're doing.
This is a very different
value proposition.
Again, hopefully, I've
made that clear to you,
and you understand that
in today's conversation.
I thank you for
coming one more time.
And politely ask you
that this is, once again,
going to sound strange,
but we're not here
to be one more hosting
provider in the cloud.
We're here to
change how SAP runs.
I have a lot of very
talented people at Google
who endeavor to
do that every day.
But ultimately, it's
for you, but it's also
with your assistance.
If you appreciate
this, A, we need
the phone call when
you want to try out,
or, B, I need you to
understand this message.
And I need you to start
setting that criteria
when people come in and say,
hey, we need to go forwards.
The answer is there's a
different way to do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]